Trascrizione: Federico Sangati
Revisore: Ariana Bleau Lugo
Buongiorno a tutti!
Oggi voglio raccontarvi
come un boccale di birra
ha cambiato la mia prospettiva
sulla leadership.
Ero negli Stati Uniti e stavo facendo
delle ricerche di master
e un pomeriggio esco,
vado in un bar, mi porto un libro
e come spesso mi capita
mentre leggo e mentre bevo una cosa
comincia a farmi i fatti degli altri,
cioè cominciò ad ascoltare
conversazioni altrui.
Davanti a me c'era una coppia
che sto parlando di cambiamento.
Lui diceva a lei:
"Dobbiamo cambiare casa!"
"No, tu devi cambiare
i tuoi atteggiamenti!"
"No, tu devi fare questo!"
Insomma, il cambiamento
era un tema centrale.
Stamattina i miei colleghi
ce l'hanno presentato in modo chiaro.
Quello che è interessante
rispetto al cambiamento
come ha detto anche prima la collega,
noi tutti affrontiamo il cambiamento
come se fosse la cosa più normale.
Ti dicono che devi cambiare,
che è normale,
che devi fare qualcosa.
Però in realtà,
quando tu ti approcci al cambiamento
la prima cosa che hai
oltre alla paura,
senti proprio la tua diversità,
sperimentati la tua diversità
ti senti lontano dall’obiettivo,
senti che in questo cambiamento
sono coinvolte tante persone.
Stamattina ci sono tante persone
con intelligenze diverse,
ognuna delle quali ha più intelligenze,
e tu sei lì a misurarti e dici:
"Ma adesso che cosa faccio?"
Allora sembra che da questo
concetto del cambiamento
che è la cosa più normale,
in realtà non se ne sappia uscire.
L'opportunità sembra qui proprio data
invece dalla diversità.
Come integrare tutto ciò
che a me suona diverso?
Ricordo un giorno mia figlia Carola,
eravamo a casa
e avevamo una coppia di amici gay.
Allora ad un certo punto
eravamo a cena e lei dice:
"Papà, ma perchè Alessandro e Luigi
sono due uomini?"
Dico: "Carola,
veramente siamo tre uomini!"
"No, no! Loro due.
Tu sei con mamma!"
Io l’ho guardata ed ero già perplesso
dalla domanda
perché non sai mai cosa rispondere
ad un figlio, soprattutto se piccolo.
Dico: "Beh, Carola, loro due si amano."
Ora questa diversità, in realtà,
è proprio la chiamata
a far qualcosa di diverso,
a costruire, a modellare,
a trovare una risposta di senso
e questo è un po’ la difficoltà
perché se da una parte dici
voglio crescere
in una cultura del cambiamento
dall'altra c'è bisogno
di creare leader del cambiamento.
Io ho lavorato tanti anni
dentro le aziende.
Oggi mi occupo di consulenza,
quindi continuo a lavorare
con le aziende e con le persone.
Non è la cosa più immediata.
Anche i leader più brillanti
faticano in questa cosa.
Allora sempre bevendo questa birra
ad un certo punto comincio a scrivere,
sempre negli Stati Uniti
a scrivere su un foglio
la parola CAMBIAMENTO,
accanto a questa parola
comincio un pensiero
che mi porta via non so quante ore
e comincio a mettere dentro altre parole
metto TRASFORMAZIONE,
metto CREATIVITÀ,
fino a quando così per gioco
comincio a mettere queste parole
e formo un acronimo CATCH
che in realtà è come una presa.
L'atteggiamento che secondo me
un leader deve avere,
deve saper stare,
deve saper prendere,
ma essere presente
e guidare il cambiamento.
CATCH è un acronimo e stà per:
“Creative Agent
of Trasformation and Change”
ovvero “Agente Creativo
di Trasformazione e Cambiamento”.
Qual'è l'elemento nuovo qui,
per me, almeno?
L'elemento nuovo è nella dimensione
non solo di cambiamento,
noi siamo chiamati spesso
per gestire il cambiamento.
Change Manager.
E poi di fatto quello che ci accade
è proprio invece di dover fare altro.
Allora il cambio di prospettiva
che ho pensato
è quello di fare questo salto,
dal "fare le cose, ricoprire ruoli,
fare i progetti,
portare le persone
da una parte all'altra",
ad "essere" e in questo essere
che c'è di mezzo una trasformazione
che coinvolge anche te,
coinvolge anche me.
Non è “faccio un progetto
e sono pagato sul progetto”
ma “qual è la trasformazione
che porto?”
E tutto questo lo realizzo
grazie a che cosa?
Allo sviluppo del pensiero creativo
che è un pò la leva
che fa muovere questa trasformazione.
Perché nel fare questo
se è vero che lavoro su di me
d'altra parte però mi dò il permesso
di avere paura.
Però mi dò anche il permesso
di esplorare, di immaginare cose nuove.
Un po’ la capacità di sognare.
Allora questo modello
ce lo siamo immaginati
attraverso 5 pilastri fondamentali.
Il primo stà proprio nella trasformazione.
La tua trasformazione vuol dire
che ognuno è creativo a suo modo.
Finalmente non paliamo più
di creatività come qualcosa
legata alle persone talentuose,
ai geni esclusivamente, agli artisti,
o a qualcuno che magari in azienda
si occupa di marketing
piuttosto che di comunicazione.
Ma creatività è qualcosa
che riguarda tutti
al di là del contesto nel quale ti trovi.
E se questo è vero,
è anche vero che tu puoi apprendere,
puoi allenare la tua creatività.
Semplice, stamattina abbiamo iniziato
con un tool, il brainstorming,
e quello è uno dei tool
che permette di allenare la creatività.
Cosa fai col penso creativo?
Cerchi di lavorare sul pensiero
divergente e pensiero convergente.
Ma questo da solo non basta.
C'è bisogno di fare un salto
e di fare un movimento un po’ deliberato.
Cominciare a coinvolgere quella che è
la sfera emotiva, la sfera delle emozioni.
Abbiamo sentito parlare
di intelligenza emotiva prima.
Ecco, attingere proprio
all'essenza di sé, alle proprie emozioni.
Quelle forti,
quelle che ti fanno sentire un eroe,
ma anche quelle che ti fanno
sentire con la paura.
Quando senti che non hai coraggio
e devi fare il salto e non ce la fai.
Ecco, anche quelle!
Quando tu sei consapevole
delle tue emozioni
ti puoi permettere
di sospendere il giudizio
e di lanciarti in una generazione
di opportunità.
E la cosa interessante
è che nel fare questo
non è che tu rimani
indifferente al contesto,
cioè non è che tu fai
una modifica di ruolo.
No, tu entri in una
trasformazione che è personale,
la consapevolezza delle tue emozioni
ti porta a fare questo.
Ora potremmo citare
numerosi esempi di leader
che hanno fatto questi passaggi.
Solo per soffermarci in campo italiano,
sicuramente merita Marinetti con Grom.
Ma al tempo stesso anche Chicco Milano
è stata premiata l'altro giorno
come l'azienda di maggior estensione
globale per innovazione
ed è in crescita al 67%.
Questo per dire che le vere trasformazioni
riguardano l'interno
ma hanno poi un impatto
nel contesto in cui tu operi.
Così il terzo punto
è proprio quello di lavorare
per creare in modo responsabile
delle opportunità
diciamo in gergo “creare il clima”.
Ma in realtà io non sono tanto
per l'idea di gestire,
ma quanto per nutrire,
perché la vera difficoltà oggi
stà nel supportare i leader
a identificare
che con i loro comportamenti
possono generare
qualcosa che ha un impatto concreto
all'interno dei contesti organizzativi.
Che cosa intendo dire?
Che nutrire vuol dire che quotidianamente
tu costruisci il contesto nel quale
le persone possono dibattere sulle idee.
Possono avere uno spirito libero.
Possono relazionarsi, ma possono anche
permettersi di sbagliare.
E questo non è così semplice
nei contesti organizzativi
perché c'è sempre l'alibi dei risultati,
come se i risultati si raggiungessero
solo in un solo modo.
Dall’altra però dare ai leader
l'opportunità di costruire un clima
con le protezioni
gli offre anche l'opportunità
di esplorare nuovi confini.
E per far questo non è così immediato.
Non si sa perchè noi cresciamo
con uno spirito immaginativo.
Chiedi ad un bambino di immaginare
qualcosa e subito lo fa.
Se lo chiedi ad un adulto
lì comincia la competizione.
Lo dico o non lo dico?
Il disegno che ho fatto
forse non è il più bello
meglio che non lo dico,
e stare in silenzio
comincia tutto questo dialogo interiore.
Quello che è interessante
quando ci troviamo in questa situazione
è proprio come faccio a concedermi
di coltivare lo spirito creativo?
E qui l'impatto che tu hai
quando fai questo,
quando ti concedi di sognare,
ha un impatto
che poi necessariamente si riversa,
se sei in un contesto organizzativo,
anche sul reinventare
la relazione col tuo cliente.
Perché la prospettiva
è completamente cambiata.
Ora per tornare
a quella birra iniziale.
Ecco, l'idea è proprio
poter fare un paradigma,
cambiare il proprio paradigma,
ovverosia che cosa?
Trovarsi nella situazione
di essere consapevoli
di allenare lo spirito creativo,
ma di mettersi in modo deliberato a dire:
In che modo oggi posso essere curioso?
In che modo oggi girando per Trento
o osservando le persone che sono qui
posso coltivare la mia curiosità,
la mia immaginazione?
In che modo osservando le persone,
posso trovare qualcosa
che non è così scontato?
Quindi il senso dell’attenzione
che abbiamo visto prima nel video
è la guida e il volano per lo sviluppo
del pensiero creativo.
Ma questo presuppone chiaramente
il coraggio di creare degli spazi fisici
dove tutto questo è possibile,
ma soprattutto
quello di creare uno spazio mentale,
uno spazio emozionale,
darsi il permesso
di far accadere le cose,
prima dentro di sé e poi fuori.
Quindi in poche parole,
il coraggio di osare.
Grazie.
(Applausi)